back with us in the bay and here at
chase center tonight
24 time grammy award winner
the one and only jay-z
yeah even with a grammy and a life lived
in the spotlight i never tried it for
anybody else singing
blue ivy carter still doesn't love being
the center of attention at least not all
the time
the one and only jay-z
check out blue and her pops jay-z
sitting courtside at game five of the
nba finals warriors versus celtics the
rapper lights up for the camera but when
his ten-year-old daughter realizes she's
also on the jumbotron she gets a little
shy and blue we don't blame you
grammy award winner
the one and only jay-z
embarrassment aside it looked like a
fun-filled father-daughter date night
for jay and blue the duo sat courtside
at the game and looked fashionable as
ever
jay in a casual black t-shirt black
pants and white sneakers
and blue in a similar fit black leather
jacket relaxed joggers and nike kicks
her shirt brown skin girl merch straight
from her mom beyonce's online boutique
[Music]
but it's her hair and hoop earrings that
have fans doing a double take blue looks
exactly like a young bee
this makes me proud but we're not the
only ones who see it b's mom tina posted
this side-by-side video on instagram and
wrote in the caption like mother like
daughter i'm very happy an eyewitness
tells e.t the youngster was living her
best life at the game quote blue is so
cute and was so excited she asked to go
meet the players
well blue asks and blue receives
yep blue got some one-on-one time with
warriors star steph curry
and from basketball royalty to rap
royalty check out blue hanging out with
the bay area's very own e-40
the carters are clearly a family who
believe in playing hard and working hard
[Music]
the trio teamed up for that cute video
last year blue crashing her parents date
night and when e.t spoke with jay he
gushed over why he loves working with
his leading lady b
she's uh
super um
detail oriented obviously as you can see
from her work and she's a incredibly
hard worker super talented
very inspiring cheers to more carter
collabs in the future hopefully none
involving any jumbotrons
the one and only jay-z
[Music]